this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you Rebecca for the brilliant
introduction and it's been such an honor
over the past several years to work with
you and and with the range of wonderful
collaborators you've already mentioned
and so I brings me so much happiness to
share this work with you because it
represents so much I'll turn on my video
for a brief moment so you can see my
Indian couture but I'll turn it off to
preserve my internet connectivity but
yeah it brings me so much joy to share
this because it represents a lot of the
work that I've done but also a huge
amount of effort on the part of hundreds
of smallholder farmers in India and so
I'm really glad that you'll get to share
in their journey as well so without
further ado I will be giving this talk
today on participatory research as
mycotoxins surveillance and intervention
strategy for resource for Indian
communities and so there's to give a bit
of structure for today's talk I'll be
walking you through three guiding
questions which are closely aligned with
the three dissertation chapters that are
coming out of my India work firstly I'll
be asking how our mycotoxin risk factors
distributed within and across food
systems and secondly how do you identify
intervention options based on those risk
factors that are appropriate for meeting
local needs and thirdly once you've
identified localities that are
vulnerable to mycotoxin contamination
how do you translate identified need
into meaningful actions that can result
in safer sustainable food systems and so
before we dive into what I've been
working on I'll just give a bit of
background on my past and those who
don't already have familiarity with this
concept so mycotoxins are potent fungal
secondary metabolites that contaminate a
range of food and feed commodity
and are thought to contaminate upwards
of 25% and even up to 80% of the global
food supply according to some estimates
and these toxins are associated with
massive monetary losses both as a result
of their influence and crop productivity
and trade but also associated with their
healthcare herd and and the more
important mycotoxins in dietary
exposures that can cause adverse human
health and nutrition outcomes and the
negative effects of mycotoxin exposure
are most pronounced in resource-poor
communities particularly in the tropical
developing world where conditions are at
the same time most amenable to a fungal
proliferation and also these communities
are often least equipped to take action
against contamination events and so
while there are many many mycotoxins of
importance i'll be focusing this talk
today and i focused my dissertation
research on three particularly important
mycotoxins aflatoxin which is produced
by Aspergillus flavus
which and is commonly associated with
maize and ground nuts a few manas n'
produced by Fusarium curtis lu ids which
is commonly associated with maize millet
and sorghum and the oxygen about jacques
scene of Allinol or dawn attract OTC
mycotoxin produced by Fusarium Grameen
Iran which is commonly associated with
we eat maize so mycotoxins really can
accumulate at Tver nodes along the food
value chain from even the very earliest
seedling stages mycotoxin genic molds
can start to a CA with developing plans
and up through grain filling crops in
the field are susceptible to grain molds
which can result in mycotoxin
accumulation and furthermore
contaminated produce can continue to
become mycotoxins in the storage
environment if storage conditions are
suitable for continued proliferation of
these
fungi and so while mycotoxins can and do
accumulate at these various nodes along
the food value chain those nodes are
also complemented by a range of
intervention opportunities that can be
injected at each point for example
seedling molds can be controlled by good
agronomic practices grain molds can be
managed by application of timely inputs
such as fertilizers pesticides and
irrigation storage molds can be present
prevented by proper drying and good food
hygiene and then of course prior to
consumption careful sorting out of off
type grains can be a final preventative
measure
protecting food it from or preventing
food from entering the diet and so with
this background underway let's dive into
the first question that I'll be talking
about how our mycotoxin risk factors
destroyed within and lost food system so
to tackle this question back in my first
days as a TCI scholar in 2016 I
conducted an exploratory survey
evaluating food management practices and
asked aflatoxin contamination status
across four diverse food system contexts
in India maharaja and district in the
north moon gear district in the north
condom all in the east and Mahanagara in
the south and so these diverse food
systems have really rich and distinct
cropping systems which are which
correspond to distinct risk profiles for
alpha toxin accumulation and so one of
the outputs of this survey that I sought
to develop was a system for assessing
aflatoxin risk level in households
across these Indian food systems and so
the alpha toxin survey allowed us to
determine that between 30 and 80 percent
of households across these diverse food
systems yielded samples
were contaminated with aflatoxin and so
you can see here in middle figure here
and the blue portion of these bars
corresponds to the proportion of
households with no aflatoxin and the red
portion of the bar corresponds to
households with detectable with samples
that had detectable alpha toxin and you
can see that across these different
regions there were different levels for
example in my book Naggar 82 % of
households yielded a detectable sample
and so we wanted to dive deeper and
understand what features of the food
system give rise to these differential
experiences and household level
contamination and as we expected the
differential susceptibilities of
different oddity types is playing an
undeniably important role so on the
x-axis here we can see the four
districts and then if you look at the
panels for groundnut maize and sorghum
as highlighted here we're seeing that in
the districts where these commodities
were were present in the food system we
observed rather high levels of
contamination
whereas pearl millet oil seeds pulses
and wheat have very much negligible
levels of aflatoxin contamination right
it's sort of an interesting case as it
is such a major staple food and across
these food systems we observed frequent
contamination in rice but very few
samples that exceeded the Indian
regulatory legal limit of 15 parts per
billion and so we can conclude from this
that commodity really is playing an
important role in shaping the detection
outcomes but if we even zoom in farther
towards sample detection rates we can
see across the four districts maharajah
gundam gerakan dhamaal and mauve negara
that within each commodity type that
detection rates were quite moderate and
so we were really keen to understand you
know what is resulting in a red sample a
contaminated sample versus the blue
sample and are there features of the
food systems that we can identify that
might give rise to detected
more often than not and so we already
had some idea of the major drivers of
aflatoxin risk we are not the first
people to want to understand this and
there's a rich literature pointing to
different risk factors for alpha toxin
accumulation particularly we know that
pre-harvest a group climatic features
are very important permanent latoque sin
levels for example there are known
relationships between drought
temperature and soil nutrition and
aflatoxin status I'm showing this figure
here where in this study they compared
ground nuts produced in without drought
stress as indicated by this red dashed
line compared to ground nuts grown at
varying levels of drought stress and we
can see that the population density of
Aspergillus flavus is significantly
higher in ground nuts produced under
drought stress conditions and so you
know there's an abundance of evidence
pointing toward these pre harvest Agra
climatic features as important
determinants of aflatoxin but sort of a
disadvantage of considering these as
intervention opportunities is that it's
quite hard to act against Agra climatic
realities in the way that can be
achieved by smallholder farmers for
example if a farmer wants to combat
drought conditions they might be
interested in irrigation infrastructure
which is often very expensive sometimes
more expensive than the ordinary
smallholder farmer might be able to
afford and so we wanted to understand to
what extent post hoc risk management and
particularly post heart beef beers might
be useful for identifying intervention
opportunities that come at lower cost to
farmers than combating the elements
pre-harvest so it's already known that
economic practices post harvest
practices and culinary practices all
influenced aflatoxin exposures in their
own
and there's been on a case-by-case basis
some demonstrated relationship between
socioeconomic status and mycotoxin
outcomes and so we really hypothesized
that some low costs behavioral practices
might be targeted for athletics and
interventions in a way that's accessible
for farmers and so in this study we
really had three major goals first to
understand the dynamics of food systems
that were surveyed in this context but
also to relate toxins status to what we
recorded in the household level survey
you know the crop protection practices
the food preservation practices and
other management tools farmers were
using and how those related to risk
status and the ultimately we hope to
create an index of household alpha toxin
risk status so when we think about
creating a risk index it's really a
matter of predictive modeling and so we
identified six post-harvest related risk
factors a priori and evaluated them for
their associations with aflatoxin status
the full set of predictors that we
considered a priori were commodity
susceptibility storage time storage
vulnerability food preservation
practices and household property
practices and landing status sort of as
umbrella representation of stable wealth
and resource access in the household
we used a forward stepwise logistic
regression to test these variables for
their associations with household
aflatoxin status and included four of
the six in our index validation pipeline
based on their effect size and key
values in their association with
aflatoxin status interestingly and
unexpectedly the two storage time the
two storage related variable bowls
didn't have significant effects on
aflatoxin status but we were able to
move forward with the other four and in
order to come
and index we developed a scoring system
for each of these four where each
element of risk was given a score from
two to five according to threshold
values derived from the literature and
we represented the index in two
different ways
first I a summative composite score by
adding together all of the four risk
index components and secondly a
disaggregated score that includes each
of the four predictors as separate
covariance in the in the prediction
model and there are pros and cons to
either approach the major advantage of a
summative composite score is that it can
be easily calculated and immediately
interpretable
by even someone without any modeling
experience assuming it has adequate
predictive value but then the advantage
of the disaggregated modeling approach
was is that at least theoretically has
more potential to be to yield higher
higher accuracy in its predictions so
what we found in a repeated five fold
cross validation is that both the
composite and the disaggregated scores
predicted aflatoxin detection status in
these households moderately well we
achieved 61% sensitivity or true
positive rates and 65% specificity or
two negatives using the composite
summative score whereas the
disaggregated score which modeled all
for a separate covariance was able to
increase the sensitivity by ten
percentage points compared to the
composite score whereas the specificity
was statistically unchanged and so what
we're seeing here is that these risk
factors really do predict aflatoxin
status in households moderately well but
it isn't perfect and so this may be
useful just for an exploratory risk
assessment tool and ideally these would
be considered together with those also
important pre-harvest agro climatic
drivers models upon which have also
achieved 60 to 70% classification
accuracy and I suspect that
in future iterations of predictive
modeling for aflatoxin status combining
both pre-harvest and these post-harvest
indicators would achieve higher levels
of classification accuracy than either
could could realize independently so
I'll give you a sense for how we can
apply this index in context so we
constructed a predicted probability
curve of the probability of detection at
various levels of the index using our
prediction model and we determined that
there's a really definitive cutoff at
around the value of 17 on the index
scale above which more than 50% of our
you have a higher than 50% chance of
having a detected sample in your
household when we compare this to what
we actually observed in the household we
can see indeed that when a household had
an index value greater than 17
three-fourths of those households had
yielded a detectable sample compared to
just 35% of households in this top panel
B that yielded a detectable sample with
scores less than 17 and so we were able
to identify a reasonable cutoff as an
indicator of household risk status using
this system and we can even go beyond
this and think about how these
correspond to local risk profiles so in
panel a we're seeing blobs that
correspond to the numerous households
that were included in this survey where
the colors correspond to their
cumulative risk index score where
lighter colors are lower risk households
and darker colors are darker as
households and we can see that within
each locality we're able to see a range
of low to high risk scores and then in
panel B what we're seeing is the
individual components of those risk
scores on average for each of the four
locations and in this way we can see
which components of risk are more
important drivers of aflatoxin than
others so uh the the t-tests each one
component against the average of all
components just to see which one
contribute more or less than average to
a local risk profile and here in the top
panel in maharaj guns for example we can
see that the crop susceptibility score
contributed significantly less than
others to the local risk profile and
that makes sense because here in maharaj
guns the cropping system is predominated
is dominated by rice and wheat which are
not necessarily susceptible of
commodities and so while we're seeing
comparable levels of risk across all of
these locations the individual drivers
of risk across the locations are quite
different and so we can learn a lot
about how to target intervention options
from conceptualizing risk in this way so
a takeaway from this section is that
post harvest risk factors do indeed
predict household athletic toxin status
and food systems really seem to have
diverse risk profiles and these pre
harvests or post harvest management
variables do seem to be important
determinants of contamination status at
the household level and so what we've
determined is that post harvest factors
in addition to the pre harvest factors
are useful also for prediction of
aflatoxin status so moving on to the
second section once we understand how
risk factors are distributed within and
across locations how do you identify
intervention options that work for a
particular community of interest so for
this section we're going to be zooming
in to a new location altogether who now
district in India's indo-gangetic Plains
region in the state of Uttar Pradesh and
who now district is among the most
disadvantaged districts in India from
the standpoint of development status and
we selected this district because of its
relatively diverse food systems
commodities such as maize groundnuts and
pearl millet which are featured as
regular features of the diet and also we
wanted to situate this study in a
context with a low level of baseline
monitoring capacity and because of the
low development status until now that
criterion was well satisfied and
practical consideration in selecting who
now was its proximity to one of our TCI
Tarina
implementation partners GDS located in
the city of Lucknow which is nearby
so in this district we were focused in
the post-harvest context and so I think
it's valuable to give you all an idea of
what the typical who now storage system
looks like the most common method used
to store grain and who now is by burying
sacks of predominantly wheat and rice
under hay stacks of chopped rice straw
and then there are a range of
alternative storage structures that are
used in a spectrum of ways across the
district these earthen silos are used
often for rice metal drums are used for
wheat storage in some contexts and then
separate sacks like this are used for
storage of smaller quantities especially
for maize ground nuts and pearl millet
and occasionally farmers opted to store
their grain in stocks without without
the rice straw covering so we are
working in three different village
clusters the first of which is have sang
guns which is primarily dominated by
rice and wheat sort of constituting a
lower risk food system and then the
other to village clusters are in Bhangra
mouths which have more diverse food
system especially in the rainy season
where rice is come is also supplemented
by may is ground nuts and pearl millet
and so in this figure here we can see
the sample yield across six seasons so
I've throughout this presentation I'll
be representing the calendar year in
these six seasons
corresponding to pre winter winter post
winter pre summer summer and post summer
and so we can see that across seasons
and across districts there's quite a lot
of distinction in the food system
composition and so we wanted to
understand how these food system
composition trends over time correspond
to changes in mycotoxin contamination
and what we observed in our longitudinal
survey of mycotoxins
in these locations is that mycotoxin
levels themselves do not exhibit much
seasonal variation per se
so for aflatoxin in panel a week we
analyzed groundnut maize pearl millet
and rice samples across the six seasons
in all of these locations for maize and
millet we also analyzed few manas in b1
given the known vulnerability of these
commodities to a few manas and
deposition and then in wheat we analyzed
deoxy Nevadan all or dawn and can see
here across the time points we didn't
see a whole lot of of seasonal variation
in mycotoxin levels per se however we
did see trends in detection and legal
status rates if you look here in the
figure across the seasons for athletics
and detection you can see sort of a
visible trend and these figures
represent all samples across locations
and crops and for here in aflatoxin
legal rates we can also see that in the
summer months or the summer seasons a
much higher proportion of samples had
illegal contamination status again
compared to the Indian legal limit of 15
parts per billion and so we constructed
generalized linear mixed models to test
for these relationships of seasonal
dynamics and we found as expected that
the detection rates didn't have any
statistically significant seasonal
variation as they were high throughout
the calendar year but we did see a
significant effect of sea
on the odds of aflatoxin legal status
where samples collected in the
summertime had greater odds of being
illegal from a regulatory standpoint and
in a few Mohonasen because we were only
evaluating maize and pearl millet we
weren't able to observe seasonal trends
because there really were very few
samples collected between pre summer and
post summer and we in these models were
also able to detect a couple of other
predictors as being important drivers of
contamination outcomes and as is
certainly expected commodity arose as
the most important driver of
contamination status in the aflatoxin
models where as you can see in panels a
and B representing aflatoxin detection
rates and illegal status rates for these
commodities over seasons there was a
significantly higher there were
significantly higher detection rates and
illegal status rates in ground net maize
and millet than there were in rice
reference level but we weren't able to
see the same relationship between
commodity and fume honest in because as
you can see here and panel see the
detection rates and illegal rates for
fume honest in in both commodities were
consistently high so we're able to
really see based on these intersections
of commodity and time where and when
[Music]
contamination events are at their
greatest and but we really wanted to
explore further how these observed
levels of food contamination translate
into dietary exposures so we used a
standard exposure dose formula to
estimate per capita daily intake in
terms of per kilogram body weight per
day and we did this by using the mean
mycotoxin contents for each commodity in
each village in most occur cop reported
commodity consumption for that commodity
for that month any cold
and then divided it by an age
distribution adjusted average body in
the to gather the food consumption data
we had abbreviated a previously
validated tool for food frequency
estimation including portion sizes in
the North Indian context and we were
interested in comparing these to the
tolerable daily intake levels for
aflatoxin and a few monism
and so we can see here in this figure
that a consumption in terms of grams
intake of these non rice and wheat
commodities was very variable across
time in Hassan under lower risk
environment the only month the only
seasons where consumption of non rice
and wheat commodities was really
measurable on a per-capita daily intake
basis were in the summer and post summer
seasons
whereas in Bhangra MO the winter seasons
had the most consumption of of these
susceptible commodities and these
seasonal dynamics and consumption really
do track with what we're seeing in
seasonal exposures up to these toxins
here I'm showing on the top hassan gunge
and then Bhangra out east and Bhangra ma
west for each of these commodities
what is the aflatoxin b1 exposure dose
attributable to each commodity at each
season and we can see in his son guns
the only measurable dietary exposure
doses are coming from rice because of
the low prevalence of ground net maize
and militant knees food systems whereas
in Bhangra mao a much greater proportion
of dietary alpha toxin is coming from
ground net and maize with some markets
the seasonal variation and only a small
fraction coming from pearl millet and
rice those distinct bands are echoed in
few madison b1 here on the right hand
side where in Hassan guns there was
really very little dietary if you Manas
and exposure
because of the low consumption of maize
and millet in this environment but in
Bhangra ma we did see concerning levels
of of dietary few Manas and exposure
some in some seasons these levels
exceeded the tolerable daily intake
level indicated by the red line and so
we were able to see that exposures in
the diet to these toxins are commodity
dependent and in a season specific
manner so we can take it one step
further and add together the commodity
wise exposures to observe cumulative
exposures in the diet in terms of per
capita daily intake and we can see that
what we observed in the commodity wise
representation is echoed here or Hassan
guns for both aflatoxin on the top and
few Maddison on the bottom had very
little dietary exposure in any season
whereas in Bhangra mao east and Bhangra
Mao West there were there were levels of
dietary aflatoxin exposure that exceeded
the tolerable daily intake level in
every season and in few Manas in' we did
see some instances of exposures above
the tolerable daily intake level
especially in Bhangra ma West and so we
can really conclude that toxins are
present in local food systems and are
resulting in dietary exposures we've
observed that cropping systems and
dietary preferences are major
determinants of contamination outcomes
and that seasonal dynamics in end comes
can underpin contamination and exposure
events and one interesting revelation
that has come of this is that
understanding the post-harvest dynamics
of in food systems reveals important
pre-harvest drivers of contamination for
example in maize immediately after
harvest we observed that the levels of
aflatoxin were very high and those
levels stayed high throughout throughout
the seasons and so we're able to say
with reasonable confidence that the
interventions best suited for combating
mycotoxins in maze would take place in
the pre-harvest domain as opposed to the
post-harvest domain and this really
prompted us to wonder whether multiply
time point multi commodity surveillance
of this nature can aid in intervention
decision-making and that takes us to
this third and final study which is how
do you translate need into action and I
want to use this opportunity to convince
to you that while it might be you know
deliciously simplistic to say that
blanket solutions can solve every
farmers problems farmers needs are
actually very varied and nuanced and
therefore interventions must really be
matched with priorities that are of
local importance if there's any hope
that they'll be adopted and sustainable
over time and one that we can use to
identify local priorities and to conjure
intervention opportunities that are
aligned with local needs is
participatory research and participatory
research is a co learning process where
diverse stakeholders can pool skills and
address shared interests and this
technique leverages diverse sets of
knowledge from all stakeholders involved
leveraging both local and scientific
knowledge to identify solutions with
maximal impact and this study has really
been pioneering in the use of farmer
research networks which are sort of an
expansion of classical participatory
research to establish informational
feedback loops that are intended to
enhance scalability and impact over
multiple generous essentially letting
the learnings in one location influence
the learnings and outcomes in other
locations with similar needs so you
might be wondering how we know where are
we situating this study and indeed these
same villages that we saw in in our
district were the ones that I also
targeted here so we are working in the
exact same communities where we have
established
Farmar research network comprised of
farmer farmer groups that are interested
in food preservation and crop protection
so we use participatory methods to
bolster capacity and to diagnose local
needs and the output of this process was
that we were able to code design
experiments to get there with farmer
communities and implement them to to
test the efficacy of food safety
promoting interventions so to a to
assess local needs Rebecca and I
actually developed this wonderful
exercise in the field where we had
farmers draw on the beasts of paper and
through four quadrants corresponding to
home grain storage market and farm life
domains and then we had them draw a
representation of that domain from their
perspective so you see they'll draw
whatever they think their house looks
like maybe a tree in the storage they
might draw their silo or a basket many
times the marketplace meant money money
money and farm on the other hand was a
potpourri of crops geese and respective
other farm items that each household was
interested in pursuing and secondly we
asked them to proportionally allocate x
marks to these four domains
corresponding to the amount of time that
they devoted were to looking at each of
these domes where for example its
respondent a farmer who has more X's in
the marketplace spends more time working
in the market than they would in a
domestic chores for example and lastly
we had each farmer take a series of
post-it notes with little crop icons on
them corresponding to actual bags of
stored grain that they had in their
storage and placed them in their storage
quadrant and crop by crop allocate the
their bags based on the anticipated end
use of each proportion of their sacks
between home consumption use as seed on
the farm or
our sale in the market to sort of get an
idea market orientation versus
subsistence orientation and so while
this exercise was incredibly useful as
an exploratory tool for us it was also
an incredibly prolific learning
opportunity for the farmers to
conceptualize their needs and to
understand the aspects of their
livelihood that could be targeted by
interventions and so we actually were
able to transcribe this data and come to
conclusions about particular subgroups
with similar needs profiles so we
transcribed all of the data from these
worksheets which took a lot of time and
meticulous effort and conducted a
multiple factor analysis and for the
purpose of this presentation I'll
present it in a similar weight and
principal components analysis so
basically we were able to see on this
quantitative variables factor map their
coordinates of of time allocation and
grain allocation scores and we were able
to determine that this first dimension
is essentially representing an access of
home versus non home time allocation and
the second access is representing home
versus market economic orientation and
then if we split our population into
several subgroups of interest we can
understand the extent to which these
populations have predictable or
unpredictable needs or interests for
example in gender we saw that the
coordinate for female respondents was
highly co-localize dwith the coordinate
for home time and home grain indicating
that females in general had much higher
affinity for domestic work time whereas
clustering by locality actually was less
informative the clusters overlapped and
coincided with a plot origin and
therefore the particular locality wasn't
substantially predictive of farmers
needs education level as indicated by
the language in which they answered the
activity either in the
pindy or in english which would have
been attained only by the highest
educated members we saw that those with
a higher level of education than average
were strongly correlated with higher
proportions of market a market time and
market allocated grain so what we can
see here is that we are able to use
these farmers input to create
assemblages of farmers with distinct
needs profiles and actually this
together with the farmer activities
enabled us to form interest based
affinity groups in each village that
were tasked with work shopping
intervention ideas and coming up with
solutions that they wanted to test and
so one of the major findings of that
whole process was that green spoilage
prevention was a major concern of all
the farmer groups where hermetic storage
was identified as a tractable
intervention option because hermetic
storage stacks are a good analogue to
the existing stack based storage
infrastructure so we conducted a
demonstration trial in partnership with
a local agricultural Science Center and
tested hermetic storage sacks against
the conventional jute and plastic sacks
in combination with a range of natural
additives from none to local neem leaves
and turmeric powder as a bio protective
agents and we determined that hermetic
storage far and away outperformed the
conventional systems and that the
natural preservatives had really no
observable effect and you can see this
visually even by examining a
representative sample from the hermetic
storage versus the plastic only storage
where after eight months of storage the
hermetically stored wheat was
brilliantly clean with very little
damage whatsoever whereas the grain
stored in conventional plastic was
absolutely destroyed rice beetles I have
thoroughly infested this system and so
this is really a wonderful local proof
of
cept that even in a highly contaminated
environment hermetic storage is
effective in preventing insect
infestation and grain damage so we
decided to extend the opportunity to our
farmer participants to try this
technology in their home so we allocated
two sacks to each household and found
that the success we found in the
demonstration trial was mirrored in the
household trials where 96% of the sacks
were installed properly and after
installation 90% of respondents reported
having a confident understanding of of
the principles of the technology at the
end of the first season of storage 92%
of the farmers reported successful
preservation of grain using the Hermetic
technology and 100% were interested in
using the technology again in the second
season and just to sort of give a farmer
testimony of how profound this
experience was one farmer reported in
the beginning we had no information on
how to collect and keep the grains we
used to store the grains according to
our wishes and many times the grain was
wasted but I have now used hermetic
sacks and kept them for a year when I
opened them I found the grain to be
clean and safe so this is just one
testimonial of many that illustrates how
this technology really opened farmers
eyes to the prospects for food safety
that can be achieved by a simple
behavior change and so we wanted to go a
step farther and not only provide these
stacks but to establish a functional
value storage in the local marketplace
and to convince local vendors that this
is something worth their time we
conducted a willingness to pay analysis
where we asked the farmers who had
participated in the Hermetic trial in
the first season to identify their
baseline level of need so basically at
in each of these locations and the
far-left bhangra Mount East bhangra ma
West and Hasan gunge we asked them to
say at zero rupees cost how many sacks
could you realistically
and our estimates across the three
districts there were like three village
clusters rather were between 15 and 25
sacks were of baseline need but there
was a highly elastic demand for this
product we're even farmers who were
convinced that it worked well were
willing to buy much fewer bags if the
cost was more so we asked them how many
bags they would like to buy at 50 rupees
or at 100 rupees or 200 rupees each and
in all districts there was a negative
relationship between the cost and the
demand but interestingly the trends were
quite locality specific and in bhangra
mouth we saw a very elastic demand we're
at the highest price point virtually no
farmers were interested in buying the
bags but in Hasan gunge
the demand was much more inelastic
meaning that they valued the technology
more and were interested in buying it
even at the highest price point and I
suspect this is because of the relative
importance of wheat as a source of
household income in Hassan gunge
relative to Bhangra mouths and so
ultimately we partnered with three local
vendors in the marketplace and
established retail sales points for
hermetic bags in the local market and
despite our willingness to pay
projections which at 50 rupees per piece
55% of needs would have been met or 30%
of need Mehta 100 rupees for peace and
15% of need Mehta 200 rupees per piece
we were able to install the retail sales
point means providing hermetic socks at
between 65 and 90 rupees per piece but
farmers were extremely reluctant to
actually invest at the end of the sales
period only less than 5% of the reported
need was actually met by sales of
hermetic bags in the marketplace which
was really quite a disappointing but an
investment decision-making process and
so to get to the bottom of this we
developed a cost-benefit activity to
in our in our farmer research Network
groups where we enabled them to estimate
monetary value of X losses sort of front
in something is protective could save
them money later on and while people
really understood that concept they
still would rather pay less upfront even
if future losses would be greater one
farmer said the stalks are costly if
they would have been 50 rupees each than
they would have sold a lot a man thinks
it's ok if five or six kgs of grain
might go to waste
but that sacks should not be that
expensive so again we're learning a lot
about how complex farmers investment
decision-making processes are and again
this is further evidence that blanket
solutions can't really be reversal e
apply and so in the second year of trial
activities and I'll just wrap up with
two quick slides and not go into great
detail we focused our next cycle of work
on pre-harvest options particularly with
emphasis on cheap and accessible inputs
so we developed training programs for
three methods and implemented a farmer
reported performance evaluation system
where farmers would compare their
experimental treated plots with
untreated control plots identified in
their same fields and overall across
these three experiments die Thane and
forty-five ground OC treatment phosphate
solubilizing bacterial maize seed
treatment and Trichoderma powder we had
really high levels of perceived better
performance compared to the untreated
controls but when this is really a
positive outcome and we've established
access points for each of these methods
in the local environment but a
limitation to this is that the data are
very highly qualitative because of the
their farmer reported nature and really
it would be necessary to have trained
local enumerators for data collection in
order to realize quantitative evaluation
of these technologies and that's
something for future investigation so
just to conclude the three sections of
this talk
it's section 1 the takeaway is that risk
[ __ ] are diverse locally specific and
associated with food system composition
in section 2 we learned that there is
substantial seasonal variation in
mycotoxin loads and dietary exposures
and that each locality really has
specific trends that warrant particular
intervention outcomes and then in
section 3 we learned that farmer
research networks can deliver
specialized interventions that are
informed by local priorities but a major
thing to be respected about that effort
was that farmers behaviors are hard to
change and this sort of effort takes a
lot of programming attention Trust
building and careful consideration of
the many complex dynamics in a small
holder food system and so that's all
I've got for you today I just want to
give acknowledgement where it's due to
my committee members Rebecca McGarry
Prabhu and Becky for your excellent
guidance throughout this whole journey
to my colleagues at Cornell in Rebecca's
lab TCI and the TCI research group and
the statistical consulting unit hearty
thanks to my collaborator dr. sue Dini
at Chris odd in his lab group and Padma
John Mann for her constant guidance from
my very beginnings in India and and many
more they're my collaborators and
comrades at TCI Tarina in Delhi and
Mumbai and then to my implementation
partners GDS in Lucknow especially
Amitabh and the uno kvk the AG Science
Center and particularly dr. Singh and
Rama and most importantly my absolutely
amazing team without which I would have
been totally lost and completely
unproductive a Veerendra a deep Dee and
Shruti you guys were absolutely
essential and this two-year journey with
you all has been you know the most
important professional development
opportunity in my whole career so thank
you so much
and lastly to all of the brilliant
farmers their families and the adorable
cows that can
tributed to my feelings and to this this
body of work over time it's just been a
really remarkable experience and I've
learned a lot so without any other
delays I know we're short on time but I
would love to take any questions if
there are any from the audience okay so
thank you Anthony thanks to everyone um
so Gary has a question Gary do you want
to go ahead and speak or shall I read
for you I can ask
nice job Anthony appreciated your
presentation you you talked a little bit
about these illegal limits levels and
what infrastructure really exists to
enforce any of that and I assume that's
only in the marketplace when a sale is
occurring yeah you're exactly right and
that is one of the biggest challenges of
navigating regulatory climate in in
smallholder food systems is that the
only real infrastructure for enforcing
these regulations would be at markets
and particularly in export markets or
governmentally regulated markets and so
at the smallholder level there really is
no no in structure for evaluating or
enforcing these these regulations and
that is actually one of the major
drivers of this research trying to
extend interventions into communities
that are that are almost completely
underserved by regulatory infrastructure
on because it is such an additional
situation I think India in general is
now really taking aflatoxins more
seriously the right Tory landscape will
be advancing in India rather quickly
thanks Anthony I'm like just sneak in
another quick question is there any
interest there in the Atlas safe bio
control technology that's being very
successful in Africa is it is it being
looked at there yeah
so I actually just last year met with
Ron Ajit in New Delhi and he's very
interested in getting a safe established
in India I mean he he is Indian himself
and he is invested in it news you know
one of the developers of that technology
and so while now it hasn't been
widespread there is certainly vested
interest in it and I expect that within
the next few years the first
manufacturing facilities and
distribution outlets will be opened
thank you so there's some nice tribute
showing up on the chat but if anybody
has any questions given the number of
people on the line I think it'll be
easiest if you chat in just at least
your name to say that you have a
question or any indication that you want
to ask something so that I can highlight
that I might see your hand go up but up
my screen is not showing the whole
picture there yeah or else just feel
free to unmute or request it on mute and
I will also use that as a chance to give
you a tap any other questions or
comments for Anthony okay Becky Stowe
suppose is a Heskey an impressive range
of research how confident are you that
your findings are generalizable to the
next year or next or the next given
secular trends or next village may be
given secular trends so Anthony yeah
well that is a great question and of
course it's it is well known that
dynamics in aflatoxin contamination are
wildly variable year-to-year as as
determined by by you know local climates
and in production texts but I think one
thing that I've really tried to focus on
in in my research is identifying those
things that are stable over time and
while the levels of aflatoxins or fu
monofins might be variable year to year
I think
important learnings as far as the nature
of risk in a given locality and the
intervention options that might be
useful are certainly generalizable
year-to-year and but it is certainly
something that is a limitation of this
work and ideally this sort of
longitudinal surveillance would would be
done over several years to try to
account for for that variation okay so
um I would just like to wedge in a
thanks to Becky she was on international
and nutrition faculty at Cornell at the
start of Anthony's work but a sense
transitioned and now she's the president
of Goshen College in Indiana and so we
really appreciate your staying on the
committee and that's I think a nice
tribute to Anthony in itself
so next marine and man has a question
after saying great our question you
mentioned that a surprising surprisingly
small number of farmers actually ended
up buying sacks indeed we were shocked
do you think this could be in part
because farmers don't see their grains
as money but rather as food and thus
paying for food they already crew is not
a good investment their inner value of
the grain is not in terms of money yes
or any oh that's a very elitist nominal
willingness to pay an actual not
willingness to pay yeah very very
striking observation and you're coming
home I mean what marina has really
worded it you think farmers are willing
to exchange grain for sex instead of
cash for sex and that was Sayyid Syeed
some variation on the question but yeah
that's a really great point yeah a
really good question because I think
you're saying that they don't see their
grains necessarily as money or something
with transacted value but rather as food
but I think that grain is the major
source of livelihood and income for
these communities and so in at least
from what I've observed the distinction
between grain for money and grain for
food is not really there because the
farmers have us
amount of grain and devote it to
different end uses as per their needs so
do I think farmers are willing to
exchange grain for sacks I would say it
depends on how much grain they I don't
think they would exchange a sacks worth
of grain for one sack but um but I I
think to get at the heart of your
question is how else can we incentivize
their investment and I think this is
something that Rebecca and I have also
been talking about is like how what are
alternatives to just outright buying
them on the market and I think that
instead of an exchange a swap of grain
for sacks well one thing that Rebecca
and I have been talking about is the
opportunity of like a risk-free rental I
think farmers would be very keen to take
take sacks out on a rental basis or pay
a small fee to rent sacks if they would
have the promise of getting that money
back so I think that there are certainly
other ways to transact and commoditize
these intervention opportunities that
have yet to be explored but I don't know
if I can say definitively whether
farmers were generally distinguished
between grain as food or money but very
good question we have now exhausted our
out for and I wanted to really thank
everyone for being here now 42 people on
the line and a really active Q&A so
thank you so much for joining us thank
you Anthony for great presentation thank
you Prabhu and TCI and thank you to the
to Anthony's committee for great
guidance throughout we look forward to
the exam so thanks everybody and best
wishes hope you're staying safe and sane
if this very weird time of our lives
take care yeah thanks it was a pleasure
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu